monkey's bum
yup you seen it right because that is
the name do exist in the official chess
database and whether you like it or not
you really want to play this opening
because imagine if you beat your friend
enemy or opponent with this wonderful
Gambit then you have a lifetime chance
to say about it that look I have beat
you with my monkey's wow
so without the further Ado let's get
started
after E4 and G6
the main move in this position is D4 but
our favorite Gambit start with Bishop to
C4
immediately looking at the F7 square and
the interesting point is after Bishop to
G7 we play like a pure beginner
Queen F3
where we are looking for the scholars
made on F7 if allowed
and guess what here we introduce our
first trap yup adjust third move of the
game that if your opponent continue with
some natural moves let's say Knight to
F6 then after IFA you are going to win
the peace at just
fourth move up the game
isn't that amazing
well the Knight cannot move because of
the F7 made and if black goes for the
counter-attacking such as D5 then you
can take the Knight hitting the bishop
so more or less black has to take the
spawn and after Bishop takes D5 if you
count the material yes indeed white
emerge with a peace advantage
so that is a small trap if your opponent
continued with Knight to F6 at this
position
okay more or less everybody will Spot It
and they are going to defend this
position accurately with E6
and after this
here comes the super surprising and yet
very aggressive Gambit and that is D4
a starting point of our wonderful
attacking chess Gambit
okay black has few options and in our
first part we are going to look at what
happen if your opponent take this Pawn
with the bishop and in my next episode
we are going to look what happened if
black decline of a gambite
okay Bishop captures D4 accepting the
Gambit and White's big point is he wants
to play Knight to C3 so that for a
one-pawn loss he get a tremendous peace
development and our next Target is to
play Knight to E2 and attack this bishop
where black is going to lose more time
in the opening
okay as per the database there are few
choices and amongst them Bishop to G7 is
by far the most popular response
however in case if you are wondering
what happens if your opponent take this
Knight well then we can simply recapture
with the queen and now as the dark
Square Bishop disappear from the board
look at the squares around the king side
they are severely weak and with the
bishop pair white has a tremendous
compensation in this line
so nope that's not a good idea by the
Black
the correct choice is to play Bishop to
G7 saving your most important piece and
after this okay many of the games
continue with other moves
but we are looking for the more
attacking option and accordingly H4
fitting to the correct response
the idea is very obvious we want to play
H5 and rip apart the black king side
so accordingly black has few choices
the most natural here is to play H5 and
stopping White's idea however black and
try other moves such as Knight to C6 but
in that case white attack will remain
very strong on the king side
so let's start the most famous Choice
namely H5 stopping White's whole idea
and not to worry as we are going to
continue with this very tricky move
Bishop to G5 with sets up for the
platform for yet another some of the
trap in our
for example black can already go wrong
if he continue moves a chance Knight to
E7 or F6 as this leads to the disaster
let's find out how
if Knight to E7 then we can play Bishop
to F6 and more or less black has to take
this bishop because if he plays any
other moves let's say castle then we can
take on G7 and after King takes G7
yup you guessed it a very simple idea
that is G4 and all what you want to do
is Castle on the Quinn side and then
become hellos with capture on H5 where
Black's open King gives white all sorts
of fun in this line
so nope that is right out of the
equation
that means black has to capture this
bishop but after Queen takes F6 and Rook
to G8
white has a very simple idea to execute
namely Castle on the queen side and the
target for wicking sitting in the center
well would you believe the most natural
move in this position Knight to C6 leads
to the blunder yeah you heard it right
because after this white has just one
move and that finished the game namely
Knight to F3 where Knight is coming on
G5 and F7 is a clear-cut target
and surprisingly even though black can
see this one is coming
unfortunately he cannot do anything
about it
for example
after D6 and Knight to G5 there are two
ways black can defend this position but
neither of them can save the game
if they play Knight to E5 then the
simplest is you play f o allowing them
to capture your Bishop but in return
after quintix F7 King to E6
Queen captures E6 and King 28 white can
simply regain the peace and become upon
Advantage where black king is stuck in
the center for the all sorts of attack
so nope Knight to IFA is a big time
blunder here guys so let's check out the
other move namely Rook to f8
well this time around even the worst new
strike after Queen to G7 where white has
idea of Knight to X7 and nabbing The
Rook something which black has to
prevent immediately
and
there is a game of Grand Master from
this position where black continue with
Knight to G8 and after Knight to at
seven black plays Queen to E7 at least
trying to defend the Rook
but sadly enough the lightning strike
from the different direction and
Grandmaster was in really attacking move
so he played the right idea Knight to B5
looking at the juicy C7 Square
had in fact the game finished very
quickly after F5 white plays Knight
capture C7 check and King to d8 we have
some forcing captures
Queen takes E7
King takes E7 and white has a luxury to
pick which Rook he wants to eat first
and after this obvious enough the game
doesn't last long as Knight takes a fade
King takes a f8 and Knight captures
eight black realize he lost two of his
rook and he has nothing to play so he
resigned the game
so this sort of fun happened when you
opponent plays the passive move Knight
to E7
the second move F6 is equally very bad
here because now when white retrieved
the bishop he has a clear-cut Target
namely G6 pawn and in a long run this
gives a great headache for the black cat
for example recently I was fortunate
enough to get this position and this
game will show you how easily you can
crush your opponent with some good
preparation
okay black plays Knight to E7 trying to
Castle I simply responded with Castle on
the queen side
and white already has a thread so for
example if a careless opponent continue
with Knight to C6 then Bishop captures
E6 gives white a great advantage
so that means here more or less black
has to stop this threat and the only way
to stop this is by playing D6 not
allowing Bishop takes E6
but after all this just look at this
position black has wasted so much time
moving the spawns and accordingly white
can exploit it very quickly I think you
already guess why its next response
yup that's very important lever G4 gives
him a nice age at the opening stage
well my opponent first captured on G4
and after quintix G4 he lash out with E5
a discover attack to the queen but after
Queen to F3
the disaster is not far away as after
Knight to C6
rightly so H5 appear on the board and
after this black position is completely
collapsing
well he tried F5 trying to trap down my
Bishop but after Pawn takes G6
Rook takes H1 Queen takes H1 and F4
white has a fantastic shot here namely
Bishop F7
King to f8 and then the sacking the
whole piece with quintuit seven where
black king really remains in a pathetic
position
well my opponent was very greedy and he
captured this piece but this is just
asking for it as after Pawn takes E3
white pieces are just literally coming
near to the black king and there is no
way in the world black and hold on to
this position
so I think this model game and ideas
gives you enough information how you can
play against the move F6
last but not least what to do if your
opponent continue with Bishop to F6
which I personally think is the best
response and against this I am going to
recommend a straightforward approach and
that is Knight to H3 defending our peace
White's Big Time idea is let's say any
black move Knight to C6 we want to
Castle on the queen side and then become
Hallows on the king side and if you
carefully look at this position white
has almost all the pieces out and the
Rooks are connected where black is
really struggling with the King sitting
in the center
okay there are already few ways black
can go wrong here and amongst them the
number one is Knight to D4
can you see why it's next move
yup simple one Rook captures D4 and that
Bishop is a complete pin
sovia peace up and winning
and that's the reason why Knight
captures D4 is not possible what about
other night move let's say Knight to E5
well again not to worry
we can calmly play Queen to E2 and after
Knight captures C4 and coin capture C4
this time around white has a threat of
Knight to B5 and looking at the C7
Square so black has to stop it but that
run into the different problem namely E5
Bishop to E7 and then Knight to E4 where
our Knight is going to launch on this
juicy D6 Square
something which gives black a big time
headache for the rest of the game
so considering all this probably the
best option here is to play the move D6
but after White's next reply that is
Rook H to E1
white has just a dream position where
his Rooks are centralized and every
piece on the optimum square and it is
just matter of time where black position
really crumpled
how dangerous this position is for the
black let's continue with one of the
most natural move in this position
namely Bishop to D7
blocking the defile
but guess what white will play
IFA and says
somebody
stopped me
the big point is after Knight takes E5
and Rook takes E5
yes white has deliberately sacrificed
The Rook but just look at the follow-up
you get after this
Bishop to B5
attacking on D7 so C6 is force
now comes another attacking jab Knight
to E4 server threaters
not only attacking this bishop but most
importantly going to the D6 Square
something black cannot prevent it and
after the obvious sequence Bishop takes
G5 Knight takes G5 Queen to E7 white has
a deciding blow
did you spot it
congratulations if you find the Moon
Knight captures F7 where black is
completely losing
of course you cannot take with the queen
because of this Fork so that is right
out of the equation
and if black has to survive from this
mass then he has to play Rook to A7
whereupon white has a very simple
sequence Knight to D6 track King to d8
Knight captures B7
King to C7
and after Knight to C5
yes black king has been completely tied
down with the row and in order to
survive once again he has to play this
ugly move Pawn takes B5 where the end
result Rook takes D7 Queen takes D7
Knight takes D7 and Rook takes D7 yes
at a first glance it looks like
okay black has equalized because he has
two Rook against the queen but
when white plays Knight to C5
unfortunately black is going to lose one
of his Rook as if you try to save The
Rook then you get this easy checkmate
go ahead buddy try it I'm showing you
right now
Queen to B7 King to D6 and now lovely
smoothest Mage with Knight E4
now before we leave I like to quickly
point out what happened at this position
if your opponent allowed you to play H5
and recently I beat a 2200 in this line
where he continued with Knight to C6 and
after H5 his idea was to play Knight to
D4
okay I play Queen to D1
and he continued with Knight to E7
so planning is to play D5
but first I hit his Knight with Bishop
to E3 and after C5 just keep
pressurizing this Knight with Knight to
F3
if black take my knight then it really
helped me to open the G file so nope my
opponent that's why I choose the move
Knight E to C6 defending the D note
I simply continue with going to D2
and after Queen to A5
we have this lovely sequence pontex G6
Aztec G6
and then Castle
where white has finished all his
development and naturally enough my
opponent played some aggressive moves on
the queen side with B5
looks very scary but not to worry as
white has all sorts of counter-attack
ready
starting with
Rook takes her shade Bishop takes h8 now
I play Rook to H1 attacking the bishop
Bishop to F6
another attacking star with Bishop to G5
and please note in all of these lines
black cannot touch my bishel as white
has a very simple thread namely Bishop
takes F6 and then Rook coming down on
the h8 with some amazing mating Concepts
so that is the reason why in the game my
opponent tried Queen to d8
but after my next reply more or less the
game is finished
and I hope you do find this deciding
blow
Queen to F4
where black is in a complete disarray
he cannot play Bishop to E7 because of
Rook check and losing the queen
so that is right out of the equation and
in the game he choose Bishop takes G5
but after Knight takes D5 he simply
resigned the game as white has multiple
threat number one mate on abseven and
number two Rook to h8 and all together
this is a completely lost position for
the black
so I guess this model game gives you
enough information how to play if your
opponent allows you to play this
thematic break H5
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this amazing monkeys bum Gambit
where if your opponent do capture on D4
then remember this simple idea first you
play Knight to C3 and when the bishop
drop backs to G7 you have this lovely
move H4 which gives you all sorts of
attacking ideas on the black king side
and as I have demonstrated in this video
overall white get tremendous piece
development and a significant attack for
one pawn something which we are all
looking in our own games
there are no analysis on this line so
you can literally use this line as a
complete surprise weapon in the
tournament practice
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will see you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care